it has happened again thank you for
joining us on eight news now at six I'm
Brian Loftus and I'm Denise Valdez our
eight news now investigators first told
you about a 500 000 gallon sewage spill
near a creek feeding into Lake Mead
tonight they've learned even more
spilled this time 8 news now
investigator David Charles breaking this
story he's asking why this facility is
where it is all new at six David well
after a piece of equipment caused half a
million gallons of raw sewage to leak
out of this facility we asked why he was
even next to a creek that goes into the
lake in the first place now crews are
cleaning up from a nearly 900
000 gallon raw sewage spill Clark County
Water Reclamation District facility
pumping raw sewage from this Southeast
Valley plant right near Sam Boyd Stadium
up to a different treatment plant they'd
use our investigators learning something
failed at this facility late last week
leaving about 900 000 gallons of
untreated sewage seeping up in pooling
right in this area as you see from our
drone when we first alerted you to a
leak here nearly two years ago now we
asked why this facility was where it is
so close to our water source because
that seems like one big environmental
risk
why is this lift station so close to the
creek uh this is where it's needed right
this is how the area's been developed
and so as Wastewater collects and must
use gravity to drain that piece from our
interview in 2021 the Reclamation
District declining to answer our
questions about this today there are
plans to rehab this plan for 40 million
dollars of your taxpayer money and keep
it in the same place spokesperson says
they're working on getting more
information for us about this bill we
don't know exactly how much ended up in
the lake and Crews were able to recover
about a third of that spill so about 300
000 gallons we'll stay on top of this
and keep you posted as we learn more and
ask why your money is being pumped into
equipment here for now I'm David charns
8 news now David thank you in response
our 8 news now investigators reporting
democratic congresswoman Dina Titus
tweeting I am monitoring the situation
working closely with stakeholders on the
ground she adds we must ensure that
southern Nevada have access to water
quality as well as quantity David's
previous investigation found the Clark
County water quality program which would
find the Reclamation District actually
reports to the district it is unclear if
the state ever find the district for
that previous 500 000 gallon spill